[Musique]
l'abstention est le premier parti de
france avec ce chiffre historique 66,1 %
de niveau d'abstention
ils vont de moins en moins voté songez
qu'il ya 20 ans c'était 77 % de
participation aux élections régionales
et ce silence il faut l'écouter nombreux
hommes politiques de gauche et de droite
ont pointé du doigt de graves
dysfonctionnements dans la distribution
des professions de foi des candidats des
milliers d'électeurs n'ont pas reçu les
programmes et n'ont pas pu être n'ont
pas pu être renseignés tout cela était
aussi organisée de manière dont dans
l'amateurisme le plus total indigents
des milliers de gens comparent sur les
professions de foi les bulletins de vote
c'est pas la plata les gens rient cul ça
très très sur les bords des routes c'est
le convecteur diamant entre dans le
plaza est dit
bien sûr il ya des preuves de propagande
électorale je convoque ce matin les
sociétés et singulièrement la société
adrexo qui n'a pas fait son travail
correctement
c'est vrai enfin les français n'ont mail
si c'est grave bien sûr mais les
français madame ça fait longtemps qu'ils
s'abstiennent
nous sommes est de très loin le premier
parti de france avec plus de 20 points
d'avancé sur la république en marche et
10 points d'avance sur le sur le front
national c'est un échec cuisant et
cinglant pour ces deux partis existent
la république en marche dans les hauts
de france avec pas moins de cinq
ministres engagés exit la raim en
auvergne rhône-alpes dont 15 ministres
qui sont à ce point disqualifié mais
c'est la politique du gouvernement qui
est disqualifié au qu'il faut mais le
président de la république doit quand
même tenir compte de cette élection et
de se camoufler à ses membres de son
gouvernement
d'abord il doit faire un remaniement est
une claque
côté résultats sont mauvais et je ne
serais pas en train de vous dire que
finalement c'est moins mauvais que
mauvais résultats sont mauvais nous le
savons le score est tellement
catastrophique que vous porter par une
porte dérobée
je voterai pour bien
bertrand j'appelle tous ceux qui m'ont
soutenu au premier tour à faire de même
la prochaine fois en fait on fait
campagne pour maria nuit ont fait
campagne pour muselier donc ça suffit
maintenant cette histoire un mois je
commençais vraiment à voir la colère qui
me manque
on a fait valoir des idées on apporter
une campagne on a rassemblé la gauche et
des écologistes donc aujourd'hui on va
faire vivre ces valeurs en région paca
et je regrette profondément l'attitude
de ce responsable vert politique il
n'est pas à la hauteur manifestement
d'un parti qui se dit à l'écouté de nos
concitoyennes la république en se
maintenant et fait effectivement posé un
grand risque
l'ensemble de ses partenaires politiques
socialistes nationaux locaux et
nationaux locaux et même l'europe
écologie les verts lui retire
l'investiture parce qu'il veut rester je
suis ça devient une candidature
personnelle
si cette liste venait à se maintenir
elle n'aura pas le soutien d'europe
écologie verts elle n'aura pas le
soutien du ps ou du parti sera exclu du
parti
il sera bien sûr oui bien sûr je n'ai
pas le droit de jouer avec le feu
dimanche je voterai pour renaud muselier
pour battre mariani et s'attriste
cohorte le rouleau compresseur des amis
de monsieur macron ferai tout pour faire
en sorte que après avoir fait une union
entre les républicains et la république
qui a en marche
il demanderait à la gauche de jeu les
dires disparaître comme il l'avait fait
il ya six ans au moins cette fois ils
ont résisté une demi journée
on est sur le podium et je constate que
le total gauche et l'écologie fait quasi
quasi jeu égal avec la présidente
sortante ya match comme on dit nous
trouverons une coalition d'une gauche
radicale qui inclut l'extrême gauche de
monsieur mélenchon cette gauche-là a
perdu sa boussole républicaine les
discothèques vont pouvoir ouvrir leurs
portes le 9 juillet les professionnels
du monde de la nuit attendaient cette
décision depuis plus d'un an déjà
et oui ces établissements où les gestes
barrières sont difficiles à appliquer
rouvriront avec des jauges limitées et
présentation du pass sanitaires en
revanche le masque ne sera pas
obligatoire sur la piste de danse